I have a voicemail number that is two
one nine to david p a question for Lewis
in the voicemail today
hey David hey Lewis this is Tim from
Pennsylvania I got a question for Lewis
Lewis I know you're into black metal
just wondering what are your favorite
black metal bands I recently saw mayhem
from Norway open for what teen in Philly
and it was pretty amazing one of the
best shows I've ever seen in my life
so yeah I love the show guys keep up the
good work
let me know but what's your favorite now
he wants no black metal specifically
yeah black metal specifically so my
answers are not going to be traditional
really when it comes to black metal but
good good my my three favorite black
metal bands or people describe these
bands as black metal one of them
absolutely is panoptic on Agalloch some
people might disagree that's black metal
I think most people call it black metal
and blue tone Nord those are my my my
top three and are those All American
bands a panopticon is yeah yeah Agalloch
is - actually they're from yeah they're
from the United States blue down orders
from France
alright so Louis's favourite black metal
bands glad to answer questions on the
voicemail segment on the bonus show
today a ninety nine million year old
lizard is preserved in amber a gun safe
is opened with a paper clip and the new
blackest material on the planet has been
developed all of those stories and more
david pakman.com slash membership